[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
GILBERT STRANG: OK,
this is about finding
the null space of a matrix A--
any matrix, square
or rectangular.
And what does that mean?
That means, well,
in algebra, we're
solving the equation
Ax equals 0.
So A is our matrix, x is a
vector that we're looking for,
and Ax is a combination
of the columns of A.
So we're looking
for combinations
of the columns that
give the zero vector--
dependent columns,
we'll be saying.
So that's the goal.
And the new start for linear
algebra that I've suggested
solves that problem
for small matrices.
It kind of just does
it for a small matrix.
But for any matrix, or a
big one, we need a system.
So this kind of
completes the idea
by giving the system,
which uses the algorithm
of linear algebra,
which is elimination.
So elimination is
going to be the key
to solving this problem--
to finding the null space.
So that's my picture.
Oh, these are the--
I'll just mention-- the three
books which discuss this.
The Introduction to Linear
Algebra is the main textbook.
Then the Learning
from Data book--
actually, that's where
this new idea got started.
And the Linear
Algebra for Everyone
has got the idea
more completely.
So I'm sort of speaking about a
section out of that third book.
OK.
And they all have websites.
Math.mit.edu, the addresses
are there to see more.
Actually, I should
say, so these are
the key ideas of this lecture.
And yesterday, I looked at
my lecture from a few years
ago-- quite a few years
ago-- lecture seven
in the OpenCourseWare
series for Math 18.06.
So that was on the same topic,
elimination and Ax equals 0.
So a lot of good stuff is
there, but there's a little more
to say now.
And that's what
this is about today.
So OK, here are key
ideas of the lecture.
So the null space--
so now you see it in writing--
the null space is all
the solutions x to Ax equals 0.
Remember, x is a vector.
And elimination is the key and
it keeps the same null space.
And the Matlab
command is rref of A.
That's the command
that does elimination.
And we'll see the identity
matrix, we'll see a matrix F,
and the new idea was to factor
the matrix into a column matrix
C times a row matrix
R. So this is really
putting all the ideas together.
And we learn that if a
matrix is short and wide,
then there are certainly--
if we've got lots of
columns, then some
of them will be dependent
and that means that there'll
be solutions to Ax equals 0.
So here we go.
Oh OK, I'm going to
start with an example.
And elimination has
already done its job.
So what elimination
did was to get
to that-- you see that identity
matrix in the first two
columns?
1, 0 and 0, 1.
So you can't ask for a
simpler matrix than that.
So once we've got that, we can't
mess with it, so 3, 5, 4, 6,
we're stuck with--
those are our other columns.
So the first two
columns are independent.
Columns of the identity
matrix are very independent.
But then 3, 4 is a combination
of those two columns, right?
3, 4 is 3 times the first
column plus 4 times the second.
So there is an x
in the null space.
That's one of the
vectors we're after.
I'll call it a special
solution because it just
came specially from one column.
And you see it down below as s1.
So if we took minus 3 of
the first column, minus 4
of the second column, and then
plus 1 of the third column,
we would have 0.
Ax equals 0-- what
we're looking for.
And the second
special solution would
come from the last column
of the matrix, 5, 6.
So again, that's 5 of
the 1, 0 column and 6
of the 0, 1 column.
And if we put that together
into a special solution s2,
we want minus 5 of column
1, minus 6 of column 2,
plus nothing of column 3,
plus column 4, giving 0.
So in this case, elimination
has produced a simple matrix R--
simple because it's
got the identity there.
So can I show you
one more example of R
before I begin to talk
about how do we get to R?
OK, so here's another R. A
little different, though.
It's different because
it's got a row of 0's.
Well that won't
pose any problem,
but we just have to
think what to do with it.
We always move 0
rows to the bottom.
And there it is.
And it does have
an identity matrix
as the first example did, but
you see that the 0, 1 is often
column 3.
The identity is in
columns 1 and 3 here
and that makes a small change.
But the idea is still the same.
Those two columns are
the independent ones.
They're very simple.
The 1, 0, 0 and 0, 1, 0,
those are totally different
directions.
Then the 7, 0, 0 is 7
of the first column.
So that spotted a special
solution-- an x that I call s1.
At the bottom line,
you see the minus 7
of the first column plus 1 of
the second column produces 0.
If you just look at
those columns, minus 7
of the first plus 1 of the
second, everything cancels.
And the other one is going to
come from the 8, 9, 0 column.
That'll be 8 of the first
column and 9 of the third--
the two bits of the identity.
So you see that when we get to
this reduced row echelon form--
horrible set of words,
but what it means
is elimination has made
it as simple as it can be.
OK, I might have
something more to say.
Yeah, so this is summarizing
what you've just seen.
So we have the simplest
case where the identity just
sits there at the left
or the more general case
where the identity is mixed
in with the other two columns.
We can live with both.
And I'm using F for
the other columns--
the columns that are not
part of the identity.
And then it has
that extra 0 row.
OK.
And now, I want to write it--
a key part of this lecture is to
see the result this matrix R--
see it in matrix form instead
of a bunch of numbers.
Often, in the computing, you're
just pages full of numbers
and you don't see
what's happening.
So what we're looking for
is the identity matrix
and the non-zero matrix F.
And now, in that R0 case,
that second example,
there's a P. What is that
matrix P doing there?
Well, it's a
permutation matrix--
an exchange matrix.
Because the identity
in this second example
is not in columns 1 and 2.
It's in 1 and 3.
So that P has to put it there.
So that P is-- and
because P is on the right,
it'll move columns.
And there I wrote
down what that P is.
That exchanges column 2
and 3 and puts the identity
in where we want it.
OK.
So that's the linear algebra--
the matrix notation part.
Oh, and this is-- here, now
you're seeing the new start,
this C times R. So that's what
I'm suggesting that if you give
me a matrix, the first thing
I would do would be to find
independent columns--
those would go into C. And
then the matrix R would--
well, we've seen the matrix
R and that would tell me
the combinations
of those C columns
to get A. Yeah, you'll see it.
Well, this box is around
all the matrix formulas.
So we're sorting every matrix
into independent columns
followed by dependent columns
and then this permutation--
this exchange matrix P--
if they don't really
come in that order.
If we need a new order.
So all this is about
A equals CR, the new--
well, not new.
Not completely new, I'm sure,
but it's the factorization
of any matrix.
OK.
And now how do we actually
do it if the matrix is big
and we need the
computer to help?
Well, we do it by elimination.
OK, this is what
elimination is about.
What are we allowed
to do in elimination?
We don't want to mess up
the equation Ax equals 0.
I'm operating on A, but
I'm not creating or losing
any of those solutions.
So if I subtract one
row from another row,
or any multiple of one
that's the main
operation of elimination.
And obviously, the
equations are still true.
If I take 3 of equation
one away from equation two,
I still have a correct equation.
And I could multiply a row
by 15 or any non-zero number.
No change.
And I can switch any two rows.
That third one of switching
rows, exchanging rows,
is just to move the 0
row down to the bottom.
This is the example.
Can you see those numbers?
So I'm giving an example of a
matrix that leads to that very
same R that we worked out.
So you see what I'm doing now.
I'm backing up.
I know the R I want, but
I'm given some matrix A,
and it's these elimination steps
that will lead me to R. OK.
So you see A over on the left?
So it's a full matrix
A. No identity there.
But I'm allowed
to do elimination.
I'm allowed to do these
three steps when I want to.
So what shall I do?
Probably, at this point,
you've seen elimination
as much as you want
to, but allow me
to say it once or twice more.
So I would take 3 of
row 1 away from row 2.
That would produce-- that 3
that's in the original matrix
would turn into a 0.
So when you take 3
of that first row,
that would be 3, 6, 33, 51.
I subtract it and I get
just that 0, 1, 4, 6.
So I've got a much
better second row.
Now, I'm going to use the
second row going upwards.
So I'll take 2 of the second
row away from the first row.
That'll knock out the
2 that I don't want
and it'll produce the
identity that I do want.
So do you see that?
If I take 2 of that last
row, that 0, 2, 8, 12,
when I take 0, 2, 8, 12
away from the top row,
I'm left with 1 and 0.
And 3 and 5 are the numbers
that happen to be left.
OK.
So really, what has
elimination done?
This is an important
idea that I think
I never caught onto when I
was learning linear algebra.
Elimination has found the
inverse of this 1, 2, 3,
7-- of this 2 by 2 matrix.
Because it's started
with 1, 2, 3, 7 and it's
ended with the identity.
So that must have
inverted that matrix.
And then it had to
apply the inverse
to the second half of the matrix
and that produced the 3, 4, 5,
6.
So you see, this
is-- oh, I think
there's probably an example
that leads to number two.
Here, I must have thought ahead.
So it says on the
screen what I just
said, that elimination has
inverted the leading matrix.
And then it's
written out the step
H equal WF that connects the
original dependent columns
to the final dependent
columns in F, 3, 4, 5, 6.
OK.
I think elimination is
just a matter of practice
and you probably have done it.
And here is an important
point about elimination,
that you could do things
in different orders.
I spoke and I did them in
a sort of natural order,
but you could do it other ways.
But you wouldn't get
a different outcome.
You'd get the same matrix R.
Well, because the equations
are still true at every point.
The x's, the null
space of a matrix,
is not changing by
my elimination steps.
Yeah.
So let's just repeat this.
When you finally get to R, when
you've done the elimination
and you get to R with
its identity matrix,
that identity matrix in R tells
you which columns at the start
were independent.
So you need to have a way to
do that and now we have a way.
In the other opening
talks in this series--
in this series about
the new start--
the matrices were
nice and small so I
didn't need much of a system.
I could practically wing it.
But now, we need a system.
And of course, if we want to
use the Matlab or other code,
it has to have a system.
So anyway, we now have a
system of row elimination steps
and we know what it ends with.
It ends with an identity matrix
of the right size, a matrix F--
that's the other columns--
and then possibly a permutation
to tell us the order.
That's elimination.
OK and here's the
second example.
So we're moving along.
You've got to pay
attention because this
is all there is is
two examples and then
put the ideas together.
So here is an
example of a matrix A
with numbers as big as 97.
I don't know how I got there.
OK.
So there are no 0's in
the original matrix A
but elimination aims to get 0's.
Oh, here.
It got 0's very quickly
because the second row
of that matrix, 2,
14, 6, 70, that's
just twice the first row.
So when I subtract 2 times the
first row from the second row,
I get that 0 row.
So I'm now one step
along with a row of 0's.
That's great.
And the third row
improved too because I
took 2 of the first row
away from the third row
and that gave me a 0, 0 at
the start and then a 3, 27.
So are we OK?
We're at the second matrix now.
It's not finished.
It's not in its R form,
in its echelon form,
but it's a lot closer.
OK.
So what do we still have to do?
Well I look at that 3, and I'm
looking to get the identity
matrix, so I'll divide that--
sooner or later, I'm going
to divide that last row by 3
and get 0, 0, 1, 9.
But another thing I want to
do is clean up the first row.
So I subtract that last
row from the first row.
You see that?
See, I'm much closer
to the identity.
So I'm now moved on
to the third matrix.
And if you've done a lot of
these, you know what I'm doing.
I'm working a column at a time.
And notice, column 2, I
can't do anything with.
Column 2 is a dependent column.
It's seven times column 1.
I can't improve column 2.
But I can improve column
3 and that's what we do.
Divide that third, that 0, 0,
3, 27, by 3 and exchange rows.
Then you see that
the result is the R0.
So it's the R0 with the 0 row.
Yeah.
So just to repeat,
this is a matrix A
that leads through the
steps of elimination,
which we're remembering to R0.
So we're really finished
with this matrix A
because this shows
how to get it to R0,
and then we've
already seen with R0,
we've figured out which
were the special solutions--
the vectors in the null space.
So we're good.
We really have done the job.
And it remains to just see
a little bit, what did we do
and what's going on with
these other two columns?
The F columns that
are not the identity.
And you see, what
we've done is--
well, we started
with columns 1 and 3.
Yeah, so that's our matrix
C. Those are the two
independent columns.
Well how do I know?
Where did C come from?
Because that's part
of this search,
where are the
independent columns.
They're the ones that
end up with the identity
because the identity
is the way to go
to the right
independent columns.
So they're columns 1 and
3 of the original matrix.
So you see C there?
1, 2, 2 and 3, 6, 9.
Then F is the part of R
from the dependent column.
So that's the 7, 8, 0, 9.
And then I'm seeing
the dependent columns.
Yeah.
You have to do this a few times,
but all the ideas now are--
and there I've put it together.
So the idea is,
with a small matrix,
like only three columns
and maybe only two rows,
we could find C and
R almost by sight.
But now, even where we're up
to four columns and three rows,
we need a method.
And that's the point of
this talk and it was also
the point of lecture seven
in the original 18.06--
Math 18.06 on OpenCourseWare.
OK, so we've found
C and R. Good.
Good.
I think it's just congratulating
ourselves from here in.
These are remembering
the special solutions.
Oh, and then why not--
you remember those?
That second column was
7 of the first column,
so that gave that special
solution, that combination,
to give 0.
And then the other
combination gave the 0 vector.
So we've got two
special solutions.
Oh, and here is the
general principle.
Yeah.
It's very simple.
After you've got this matrix
down to identity and F,
then the solutions x
should have a minus FI.
You remember the minus
signs that we saw?
So all I'm saying
here on the first line
is that the matrix IF times
minus FI gives the 0 matrix.
Of course it does.
And then the second line is
the little bit of special trick
that you have to do if
there's a P, a permutation,
an exchange involved here.
When the identity matrix is
not sitting where you want it,
you have to have a
P to put it there.
Then P transpose has to
come into the solutions.
Yeah.
Yeah, because P
times P transpose.
So remember about
permutation matrices.
Linear algebra is about learning
different special character
of different matrices.
And permutations just take the
identity matrix and mess around
with the rows or mess around
with the columns, same thing.
And then P transpose
unmesses it.
Brings it back to the identity.
So P times P transpose
is the identity.
OK, so we're just about there.
Oh, then this is the
little point I made--
well, it's an important point.
Suppose I have five columns
and only three rows.
That means I've got
five unknowns and only
three equations.
So there are going to
be solutions to that.
There are going to be solutions
other than the 0 solution.
The 0 combination
will surely give
0, but if I have five unknowns,
five columns in there,
and I have only three
equations, three rows--
so five greater than
three, n greater than m--
then there will be
some columns in F.
There'll be some
non-zero solutions.
And these examples show.
So take that matrix
M at the end there.
You see there's a matrix with
four columns and only two rows.
So I've got four
vectors in the plane.
If I have four
vectors in the plane,
there are combinations
that give 0.
They can complete triangles.
So in that case,
rank would be 2.
So we're really seeing this
part of linear algebra,
to simplify the matrix by
elimination so that all
the main facts are clear.
Yeah.
And oh, if you really want
to see it in shorthand--
I'm not necessarily
pushing this last idea,
but if you want to
see it in a shorthand,
we could think of the matrix
as having just four blocks.
So it's a 2 by 2 matrix,
but unfortunately,
each of those guys is a block.
So W is the one in the corner
that we talked about earlier
that gets inverted.
So if we look at
the last line, that
W in the corner, that
ended up as the identity.
The second block row, the
J, K, ended up as 0's.
And the one remaining guy,
it tells us the combinations
that we are looking for--
is this W inverse H.
So let me look at that
equation in the box
W, H, J, K, that's the
matrix I'm starting with.
I'm going to invert W
and I know that J, K is
some combination of W, H.
So when I invert W, I get--
the first elimination
produces the first row,
starting with the identity.
And when I apply that to
the second, the J, K row,
those go to 0.
So that's what elimination
is doing in real shorthand.
It's taking a 2 by 2 block
matrix to that matrix R
at the end, with a 0
block row and an identity
block in the upper corner.
So that is elimination
and the solution of--
and finding the null space.
So really, this
completes the job
of the first topic in linear
algebra, is identifying--
understanding these four
fundamental subspaces.
The null space
being one of them.
The column space being another.
We understand now which
columns are independent.
And the row space being another.
And so we're really
understanding
the idea of these four
fundamental subspaces that
go into the big picture
of linear algebra.
So this completes the first
major stage of a linear algebra
course.
And then what's to
follow will come.
Eigenvalues, singular values,
applications of all kinds.
Least squares.
Good.
Good math.
And thank you very much.
So that's my summary of
finding the null space.
Good.